this is Troian Bellisario and this is
Patrick J Adams we're married
we're about to take a quiz to see how
well we know each other please say that
this goes well we did shake hands to say
may the best man win
yep and no judgment no judgment that's
what we shook hands for there's gonna be
judgment mmm-hmm check off every detail
that you're absolutely sure you know
about your significant other sure
do I know your birthday I hope so
I know your birthday I know your
birthday yours a little fuzzy me too the
day for sure I've got okay well your
birthday is October 28 1985 boomtown yep
okay and your birthday is August 27 1981
done perfect done look at us
birthday thanks for the quiz guys see
you later so that makes your age you
better know this cuz I don't really know
this completely wrong remember turning
to eight years old yes Jesus is like
Jesus here Jesus is here my Jesus here
it's gonna be big what's my words my age
mm-hmm what what's my hate what you've
already clicked them I click the button
because I know that's you are you're 30
you're turning 30 you are it's 1990 say
it right no I am you are 37 you're 30 38
good done their astrological sign Virgo
kiss I'm a Virgo no you're a Scorpio
right mm-hm
yeah okay perfect that wasn't it no it's
interesting that you say Scorpio I say
Scorpio why do I say squirt Jesse
scorpion there's a scorpion why it's SCO
well I understand that but do you say
scorpion I don't think you want to be
admitting this in front of all again do
you say scorpion scorpion scorpion yeah
this is weird what's my middle name Dave
leash
yep your middle name is Johanna CJ and
Patrick Jo dong :
the name of your first pet it's that dog
you had its in like that's in that that
pictures of you does that dog and his
name was Murph Murph Murph what Martha
I'm making it up yeah I don't think you
grew up with dogs you had cats and I was
gonna go ahead and say the first cat you
had was whisper wrong peaches wrong the
first guy you had was ghost the gasps it
was a cat named Meg we've never talked
to me I never talked about this how long
have I known you we got some stuff to go
over really the first dog that I had was
Tommy Tommy yeah Tommy the last name of
your current pets Charlie and baya
better known as beans and cheese or
madame frijoles and charlie buckets wait
what was Charlie's full name not Charles
that's Apple no but it was like the
great okay fine we're not going to do
that we made that sure we're not gonna
talk about that your favorite movie I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it and even
if you tell me I'm wrong you're wrong
your favorite movie yeah is Forrest Gump
I know it's not like your favorite like
I'm a cinephile and I'm art it's wrong
but it's 100% you would know the entire
script of it it has to be your favorite
movie favorite movies back to the future
because it's the best perfect your
favorite movie is Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless yes but I still feel like I
get to know my own favorite TV show 6
feet under
I mean do you want me to get sassy with
you since I didn't get your favorite
movie you we literally had a
conversation the other day where my
favorite shows Six Feet Under
because I didn't really what cuz it was
you need to television okay
I'm you're saying you can't start a
killing here and I'm just saying that
your favorite TV show is like fully the
wire no what is it Springs I was gonna
see Sopranos and then I thought that you
wouldn't build a wire and build a whole
world of the stuff you were gonna do we
live in this world
okay their favorite book ooh The Stand
know what stuff it's a great book but it
so what is your favorite book the Bible
calm down because it's the only book
into the wild Oh interesting do plays
count as a book know what I don't know
house of leaves wrong what is it I would
probably say Catcher in the Rye
but neither of us got that no a favorite
band I'm gonna say LCD soundsystem
pretty I'll say Arcade Fire for you I'll
go with that for sure we both get that
right we both get that right you your
favorite change food a sandwich 100% you
get it what's my favorite food an almond
croissant you know what I'm gonna give
it to you because my favorite food is
sushi like that I feel like that's my
favorite treat but he's not wrong
your least favorite food oh oh oh
wet greens like zucchini sauteed spinach
wilted green egg plant can't deal plant
not in our house oh okay what's my least
favorite food
Oh meat yeah just cuz I don't eat it
their preferred pizza toppings Oh knew
you'd oh what's that pork what's that
pork thing the always order in Toronto
do go sorry
wouldn't that be your favorite no you
could have just picked like pepper you
know you know I did I thank my very feet
to the pepperoni Ultimo there you go
that's what I said Lucifer's pizza
pepperoni Ultimo and for you it's a it's
a it's a Zucca veggie Ultimo with weed
pumpkin nice but what what's my favorite
thing to put on a pizza begins with a B
it's a special kind of cheese I'm hoping
you never get the burrata we never go to
fancy pizza place
okay try to bring that up favorite soda
so straight up coke I'd say for you what
kind of cool Oh Mexican go Claire you
yeah is a Lacroix considered a soda do
you think I live a joyless life you
don't drink soda so every once in a
while but what would be my favorite like
my favorite like fizzy drinks Lacroix
you drink it all the time it's kombucha
you don't get that right that's not a
soda I would not consider kombucha soda
I don't think you get that favorite soda
I do okay what's your favorite alcoholic
drink dirty martini
yep yours is like a mescal drink of some
sort like whatever then coolest of all
infamous Cal tequila drink is or a glass
of chardonnay but I'd say white wine
yeah their eye color your eye color is a
beautifully I think a glacier blue
you're my brown-eyed girl yeah where
they grew up Toronto Los Angeles if
they're a cat person or a dog person I'd
say that your vote yeah animals yeah
animals are the best who's your best
friend I know your best friend is Tommy
Burroughs
I think Lulu Brett would take umbrage
with that it's a Lulu Tommy it's a Lulu
Tommy combo and I'd go with a barber
recently Brendan compound cut right how
they take their coffee milk with a
little sweetener not anyone I say little
actually quite a bit go back think about
what you just said
what almond milk in a long time baby oh
you're having come on the oat no train
Oh milk sorry boo that's what we used to
have it you can take it I want you get
it you know oh you know I'm just gonna
say espresso recently you've been doing
a lot of espresso sometimes in americano
but more so as press oh sure with what
kind of milk oh because that's what I
buy exactly your favorite season Paul I
think you like fall I think your
favorite season is summer what is it we
did out of here fall their favorite
sexual position if they have one we both
know yeah we can just say that we can
just say favorite sexual you talk about
it look at me it's that one yeah we
haven't had sex yet their dream job I
would say Troy as dream job is the job
that she currently has she's an actress
she's an actor yeah I'd be an active
threat and I'd say your dream job is a
job that you have done and currently are
continuing to do which is being a
director yeah just looks good the worst
job that you ever had was I don't think
working for your mom out or got fired
my mom fired me I don't think it was
like the worst but you haven't had that
many jobs the coffee bean yeah sure yep
they're there at sports team if they
have one you don't have one the Anaheim
Ducks I don't know you don't have one
I'm joking yeah the Raptors call I know
a person you definitely don't have one
and if you say you do you're honest the
Lakers okay what are their allergies are
if
have them you don't have any allergies
wrong cats you have none
my biggest celebrity crush Michael Cera
that's actually wrong she even loves
Michael I do do you like Italian Julia
Murphy oh that is true but it's still
not the my biggest me Phoebe
no you either know it or you don't it's
a classic Gosling Ryan Gosling that's
Canadian that hurts your biggest
celebrity crush when you were younger
would be Jessica Alba no now it's Margo
rubbie
Charlize Theron yeah yeah she's magic
when they can roll their tongue you can
yeah can you yeah the name of their
first love we won't say it I hear but I
know it I know it
do you won't talk about that later okay
the name of their first grab their
favorite coworker yeah I know it I know
it if they're left-handed or
right-handed
you know it what their nickname is if
they have one yeah what their parents
jobs are if they're retired yeah yeah
favorite school subject science yeah
sure we'll go with that well I think it
was like English or drama yeah
yes least favorite school subject I
think for you that was probably maths or
science mess for you I don't know
actually I don't know no you were
bluffing the house math nerd Womack I
never did that but it probably would
have been um I didn't have one you loved
all this what a nerd their biggest fear
that's a big question
yeah let's skip that what year they
graduated high school if they graduated
they graduated high school if we sat
here did the math we could figure it out
sure well you're the graduated college I
know that yes sir you know that if they
like camping yeah you do
their favorite ice cream however this is
a point of contention you know what mine
is
I don't because you have eight billion
no no it's the one that I always wanted
a basic I'm so good eating cream what oh
I'm not that basic this is what I'm
talking about
did you go to get ice cream with her
it's not dreaming every single flavor
here
this is this is marriage cookie dough
thank you burger excuse your favorite
ice cream place I don't have them so
don't ya know I was gonna say that
because he doesn't care he goes in and
he goes with whatever his women just
whatever it is it's ice cream it all
tastes good I mean divorce later if they
like ice cream cone in a cone or a cup
coffee is a cup if they like spicy food
yes
yep if they're vegan or vegetarian or
not if they prefer cake or pie I'd say
you prefer pie I'd say you prefer cake
yep if they prefer the sheets to be
tucked in or untucked at the end of the
bed I'd say you prefer untucked for sure
and you prefer tucked cuz you like a
little like a little mouse yeah to be
tucked in their favourite swearword you
know that's all those know that their
phone number without checking your phone
100% of hundo percent what you got 43
points ah I just got 44 but that could
be contentious make news great
we know each other very well they had to
well maybe we should take it take it you
got it yeah yeah right yeah there it is
still on
[Music]
you